France Info la première ministre
poursuit ses entretiens c'est
consultations des élus de l'opposition
avant de recevoir l'Inter syndical
mercredi veuille de nouvelles journées
de grève et de manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites les représentants
de la nuque socialiste écologiste France
insoumise et communiste ont refusé
l'invitation le rassemblement national
les républicains les centristes aussi
eux ont accepté nous sommes en ligne
avec le président du groupe Union
centriste au Sénat sénateur des
Hauts-de-Seine bonjour Hervé Marseille
bonjour vous sortez de Matignon que
ressortent de ce rendez-vous
souci dialogue de la première ministre
on a pu parler pendant plus d'une heure
avec elle et Monsieur Riester ministre
en charge des relations avec le
Parlement notre souci c'était de savoir
comment on pouvait travailler maintenant
au Parlement sachant qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité qu'il n'y a pas de majorité
alternative et que ma foi on parle pas
de dissolution donc comment ça marche et
que vous a-t-elle répondu
plus de dialogue plus de concertation et
moi j'ai posé la question des
textes à venir
très prochainement au Sénat
m'a parlé notamment de la loi de
programmation énergétique de la loi de
programmation militaire de textes qui
sont moins importants et la marque et
son souci pour pour l'agriculture
également nous nous avons dit qu'il
manquait un angle à la politique du
gouvernement ces derniers temps à nos
yeux c'est l'angle social plus de
justice sociale plus de justice fiscale
plus d'équités territoriales et pas plus
d'écoute des gens qui sont dans la rue
de ceux qui manifestent de ceux qui sont
en grève depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant
c'est un souci qu'on a exprimé au début
de cette conversation avec mes collègues
et ce qui m'accompagnait pour dire que
nous trouvions un peu gênant pour ne pas
dire délicat que il n'y ait pas plus de
prise en compte
des organisations syndicales et
notamment les plus réformistes comme la
CFDT alors qu'elles avaient manifesté
j'allais dire leur responsabilité et
leur souci de d'organiser la
contestation dans les rues et donc il
nous paraissait nécessaire que que ce
travail se fasse et nous indique elle
recevait les organisations syndicales
mercredi et qu'elle entendait bien
renouer le dialogue avec elle sur la
réforme de retraite les syndicats
demandent toujours le retrait
je suis pas totalement sûr que ça soit
la vision des gouvernements
je crois que il y a actuellement des
délibérations qu'on s'est
constitutionnels qui vont être
exprimés dès le 14 avril prochain et
c'est à partir de là qu'on verra
ce qu'il y a lieu de faire ou de ne pas
faire je pense que le Conseil
constitutionnel va avoir un rôle décisif
dès lors qu'il décide par exemple de
valider la loi mais il y a certainement
une grande partie de cette loi qui
nécessiterait une loi travail vous misez
sur le Conseil constitutionnel pour
débloquer la situation aujourd'hui il y
a plus que ça
a écouté la procédure parlementaire a
été épuisée aujourd'hui ça se passe
devant le Conseil constitutionnel
Conseil constitutionnel devra dire ce
qu'il retient ou pas de la loi est-ce
qu'il l'Ascension ou pas est-ce qu'il
retire les articles de la loi et donc on
le saura 14
on peut penser qu'il y a pas mal
d'articles qui seront censurés de toute
façon il faudra retravailler
parallèlement à un texte sur le travail
texte qui aurait fait auparavant nous
au groupe de l'Union centriste de l'udié
nous avons défendu l'idée qu'il fallait
une conférence sociale avec le patronat
les syndicats parce qu'il y a une
société poscovide les gens ne vivent
plus de la même façon après le covid
quoi qu'il arrive Hervé Marseille ça va
laisser des traces quasiment indélébile
sur le travail parlementaire
ça va laisser des traces à l'évidence
surtout
chez beaucoup de familles parce que on
voit bien qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont au style à la façon dont cette
réforme a été engagée et sur le fond ce
qu'elle contient c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut absolument retrouver
les voies du dialogue avec évidemment
les les organisations syndicales et il
faudrait pouvoir travailler à cette
société posz covid parce qu'on peut pas
parler du pouvoir d'achat qui est un
sujet considérable du temps de travail
du partage de la valeur comme ça par des
textes séparés il faut avoir une vision
globale on peut pas avoir des sociétés
sociétés des entreprises qui gagnent
énormément d'argent qui distribuent
autant d'argent à leurs actionnaires et
puis avoir des bons qui sont distribués
pour que les gens puissent consommer
acheter de l'essence etc donc il faut
retrouver davantage
de justice sociale et de justice fiscale
et ça ça se fait dans le dialogue et le
partenariats Marseille ce dialogue
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas un
dialogue de sourd dans la mesure où
personne ne fait un pas vers l'autre
dans la mesure où les syndicats
demandent le retrait du texte et le
gouvernement s'y refuse
certes mais je j'espère enfin je forme
des vœux fervents pour que mercredi il y
a des avancées et que
ça peut être l'avancée aujourd'hui
écoutez déjà c'est de dialoguer c'est de
rechercher le dialogue parce que jusqu'à
présent les organisations syndicales et
notamment la CFDT demandait des
médiations entendues plusieurs fois des
perches aucune d'entre elles n'a été
attrapée par le gouvernement ils n'ont
ils n'ont pas été reçus par le Président
de la République et là ils vont voir la
première ministre c'est déjà c'est qu'il
y a un dialogue physique et à partir de
là par exemple dans la loi sur les
retraites il y a une
clause de ce qu'on appelle la revoyure
2027 pourrait considérer que on fasse
une pause en 2027 et que par exemple on
s'arrête à 63 ans et qu'on demande à
l'agirco ou au Conseil des retraites de
faire des propositions à partir de ce
que sera la situation en 2027 pour la
suite donc ça peut être ça la solution
la clause de revoir
on peut aussi considérer que dès
maintenant on demande à des
intermédiaires à des médiateurs en
quelque sorte de faire le lien entre le
gouvernement et les organisations
syndicales en tous les cas celle qui
accepte le dialogue
et merci beaucoup d'avoir pris ces
quelques minutes pour nous dire ce qui
était ressorti de cette réunion à
Matignon Hervé Marseille président du
groupe Union centriste au Sénat et
sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine